if a commodities trader tells you that a
market is in backwardation they're
essentially saying that it costs more to
buy whatever commodity they're talking
about now so now it costs more than it
would to buy it later to go into a
futures contract to buy that whatever
that commodity might be silver gold or
oil to buy it later so later is cheaper
is cheaper so the question you might ask
yourself or that really any trader might
ask themself is this bullish or is this
bearish is this a bullish situation and
there's no obvious rule of thumb here
but if someone says look to get
something now costs more than to get it
later what does that tell you about
what's happening in the market well it
tells you that people are desperate so
they are desperate because if they
weren't desperate the rational thing to
do would just be wait wait a little
while and get it cheaper for later or if
you don't need that oil right now or if
you don't need that corn right now or if
you don't need that gold right now
instead of paying more for it right now
just say look I could enter into a
futures contract for delivery of that
gold or oil or corn or whatever it is at
a later date for a cheaper price and I
wouldn't even have to store it between
now and then so if some if people were
rational and if they weren't desperate
this wouldn't happen but because they're
willing to do this they're willing to
pay more now than for a future delivery
date it shows you that there might be
some type of it tells you that there
might be some type of shortage in the
case of oil maybe you know the oil
supply has been disrupted somehow in the
case of corn for whatever reason some
crops have been destroyed and people
need to eat in all of the rest for
commodities that aren't used so to speak
like gol if you see backwardation there
i wouldn't say i mean it's definitely
still desperation but it's not out of a
core need if gold goes into
backwardation it's more because of some
type of irrational desire to have their
hands on the gold now then have it have
their hands on the gold later maybe they
need think society is going to
and the the future delivery date of gold
aren't going to actually hold up who
knows what they are so in general when
people talk about backwardation because
of this desperation in the market people
tend to perceive it as a bullish signal
obviously if people are desperate
there's demand for this thing my
argument is you can't just look at one
tea leaf out of a bunch of tea leaves
and say whether it's bullish or bearish
but what you could say is look there's
something somewhat abnormal going in the
market due to some type of desperation
it's a little less irrational if it's
due to a story storage but it could be
very irrational if it's due to just
wanting your hands on it because frankly
if you wanted to buy gold just for the
sake of investing in gold you're not
going to eat it or use it to fuel your
car or anything like that it would make
complete sense or even better if you
already held gold in this type of a
market that's going under going
backwardation the rational thing to do
would be to sell your gold now for more
money and then agree to sell it and then
agree to buy it back later for a cheaper
and so once this later date comes about
you'll still have your gold and you
would have made some risk-free profits